نبدا صباحنا هذا اليوم بالحديث عن التواصل
ولكن عن الاتصال باجهزه التواصل طوال
الوقت هذا التواصل الزائد او المفرط داخل
وخارج مكان العمل يصيب الملايين بما يعرف
بالاجهاد الرقمي دراسه دراسه حديثه بس
اكمل لك بانه تقول ان 31% من الموظفين
يفرطون بالاتصال بالادوات الرقميه وهي
ظاهره تفاقمت بعد كورونا بالفعل وطبعا في
فترات الاغلاق تفاقمت بشكل كبير لانه
احتاج الناس لقنوات مختلفه للتواصل عن بعد
من البريد الالكتروني لتيمز واتساب زوم
وغيرها من التطبيقات ايضا مواكبه هذا الكم
من المعلومات اكبر من قدرات الناس الناس
اصبحت خلف شاشاتها طوال الوقت داخل المكتب
في البيت
حتى اثناء العطلات الصيفيه تفاصيل اكثر عن
الدراسه بالتاكيد راح نتعرف عليها مع
الزميله لميس ابراهيم صباح الخير يا لميس
صباح النور راح اعرفكم اكثر عن الاجهاد
الرقمي ضروري احنا مجاهدين
الاجهاد الرقمي يحدث عندما نتلقى حرب
معلومات اضخم بكثير من قدرتنا على معالجته
ومن اعراضه القلق والارهاق يعرف ايضا باسم
الاغراق المعلوماتي او المشقه الرقميه
دراسه حديثه اشرف عليها المرصد الفرنسي
للاغراق المعلوماتي وجدت ان واحدا من
الموظفين استقبلوا رسائل الكترونيه بعد
الساعه الثامنه مساء في اكثر من 50 ليله
في السنه حاللت الدراسه فترات التركيز
الكامل او ساعه واحده من دون ارسال رسائل
بريد الكتروني وقدرت تلك الفتره بنحو 11%
فقط اسبوعيا ما يعني الكثير جدا من
الضوضاء الرقميه
واليمنزاب عالم الاوبئه والمدير العام
السابق للصحه في فرنسا يقول ان هذه الازمه
مرتبطه بزياده مخاطر الاصابه بامراض القلب
والاوعيه الدمويه بالاضافه الى تاثيرات
مناعيه اخرى يقترح باب ابقاء الشاشه مغلقه
في اوقات معينه واستغلال هذا الفراغ في
ممارسه الانشطه البدنيه او حتى مجرد
الاسترخاء
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
دكتوره منال الفحام اختصاصيه امراخ امراض
المخ والاعصاب اهلا بك دكتوره منال معنا
اسم العربيه تفضل يسعد صباحكم دكتوره
تواصل مستمر وعن طريق اجهزه فيها اشعاعات
فيها هذا الضوء الضوئي الازرق ايضا اللي
على ما يبدو مساهم بالارق كيف هذا التواصل
المستمر واللي بيؤدي للاجهاد اجهاد
التواصل او الاجهاد الرقمي اذا صح التعبير
كيف باثر على دماغنا وعملها عمل ادلغتنا
هلا طبعا هذا الموضوع حديث معنى حديث انا
لاحظته صار لي 30 سنه بشتغل يعني بعملي
اخر عشر سنين صار ملاحظه جدا وواضح ضبابيه
الدماغ وارهاق الدماغ وتعب الذاكره
بالنسبه لاعمار صغيره كتير الموضوع بيتعلق
بعتقد بثلاث محاور طبعا هو عمل الدماغ ككل
وليس العين فقط عمل الدماغ لانه عندك
ضوضاء بصريه وضوضاء سماعيه وكم هائل من
المعلومات المبعثره والمتناثره اللي هي ما
بتصب بموضوع واحد دائما في عدم وجود فاصل
استرخائي لحتى يقدر يحط المعلومه بالارشيف
تبعه للدماغ يعني الدماغ بيحتاج لوقت انه
انا بروح بنام مثلا او بعمل استرخاء بتركه
المناسب للملف ما بتكون مبحتره المعلومات
وبقدر يغربلائي لازم حطه بالذاكره اللي
دائمه اللي انا بلزمني وايلي لا ما بهم
عرفتي فعدم وجود فواصل استرخائيه اثناء
العمل وخاصه انتظام وقت النوم كمان هذا
امر كتير مهم يعني انا بعتقد انه اذا شركه
فيها موظفين كثير مهمين وبيخافوا عليهم
المفروض ما يضغطوا عليهم بالعكس تمام
ليكون ادائهم اعلى ومستمر ومتوازن ولاكثر
فتره ممكنه افضل شيء يعطون فواصل
الاسترخائيه اجباريه هذا الكلام لوسام
واشواق لا علاقه بالاداره انا قاعد اقول
وسام
خلينا خليني اسالك انه طالما هذا الدفراج
من من الصعوبه او تقسيم الملفات من
الصعوبه انه يكون في المخ في هذه الضوضاء
التي نعيشها كيف نعمل فورمات او انه نهدي
هذا المخ استعدادا للنوم استعدادا لليوم
الجديد اللي راح يجينا كم اكبر من
المعلومات تمام هلا النقطه الاولى سبعه
حديثا يعني ما في اي مجال للشك انه عمليه
التعلم والعمل هي فوكس يعني تركيز
واسترخاء لابد يعني في تقطيع للعمل لازم
يكون انه انا مركز ساعه بسترخي خمس دقايق
حتى لو عم درس اولادي حتى لو بالوظيفه
مدير واي عمل خاصه بقى جماعه الاي تي هاي
اول نقطه النقطه الثانيه انه فعلا مثل ما
انت تفضلت انه انا اكون عندي وقت النوم
مقدس فلازم يعني ما اسمح للضوضاء اللي مو
لازمتني الا انا عملي بكذا عم بشتغل
بهالموضوع هذا خليني اركز وفوكس على
الموضوع اللي انا بهمني واحذف كل شي ما
بهمني كتير سهله هلا موضوع مهم انه اذا في
ناس مزعجين بحياتي احسن شيء احذفهم ما
اقعد جملهم المجامله المجامله كتير بتاذي
الاستماع لمعارك هوائيه انا مالي علاقه
فيها ماني مؤثره فيها وما بتضيف لرصيدي من
بعملي عرفت كيف انه انا ما اسمعها ما اسمح
اصلا للضوضاء تدخل لعندي واقدر حدد شو هو
الشيء اللي فعلا بضوجلي دماغي كل انسان
عنده اشاره يعني دماغنا وجسمنا مجهز
بحساسات بقول له انه هذا الموقف هو اللي
عمل لك نرفزه داخليه او ضوع لك تركيزك انا
هذا الموقف لازم اتجنبه وهي كتير مساله
مهمه على فكره بتعلق بالحواس تعلق
بالمنراه وما نسمعه حتى ما نشم للاسف يعني
احنا بنحكي عن اجهاد رقمي وكيف ممكن انه
نبعد هاي الضوضاء طب ما هي الضوضاء جايه
من متابعه مثلا مواضيع جدليه على السوشيال
ميديا متابعه
التعليقات اللي ممكن بالفعل تخلي الشخص
وكذا بيطلع يعني شوف المتابعين لك اياه
هلا انتو عملكم يتطلب متابعه الميديا صح
ولا لا بس في مواضيع بتهم تعرفوها ومواضيع
الاحسن ما تشوفوها غربله اذا غربله هي
مساله كثير مهمه وخطيره وانا اعلم اولادي
حتى علم حالي علم اللي حواليك في غربله
هلا طبعا شرب المي مساله جدا مهمه كتير
بتساعد وانه يكون في مواقف استرخاء للذهن
للاكل دخول الحمام يعني انا لما بشرب مي
بترفض على الحمام مثلا هاي ابسط شغله يعني
التخفيف من القهوه اعطاء مشروبات اخرى
يعني موضوع مهم بس كلمه اخيره اذا في وقت
انه بيركزوا بالارهاق اللي على العين مو
العين اللي دماغ هو الذي يرهق
فحتى بيرفع الضغط بيرفع السكر بيعمل امراض
مناعيه ذاتيه الدماغ عم يغضب يعني يجب ان
نفصل تماما عن كل هذه
مواقع التواصل والتليفون اهم شيء الموبايل
هذا لازم نبعد شكرا جزيلا الدكتوره منال
الفحامه اختصاصيه امراض المخ والاعصاب
يعطيك العافيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات